raptors will inbound we've played
a little over three minutes and there's
the first field goal of the game for the
raptors friend van fleet
for three nothing wrong with that shot
great job by vouch turning and facing
quickly
powell ciacom van fleet for three
it's good and the raptors have taken the
lead
17 to 16. frank van fleet
shot clock under five a long three by
van fleet
is good his third three of the quarter
and good stuff from terence ross he
steps in off the bench and knocks down a
three for the magic
out of that timeout van fleet for three
good again by fred van fleet he's
made four from beyond the three-point
line
he has a lot of confidence in his
ability that's a big shot magic up by
three van fleet for three
he got it played more minutes per game
than any team in that 35 year stretch
there's a steal by powell he gives the
van fleet
the undrafted fred van fleet knocks down
another three his sixth of the game
[Applause]
throws it away and got himself in
trouble powell doing a good job of
playing the passing lane
and van fleet adds another three he is
on fire
seven threes in the first half
the undrafted player from wichita state
another three by van fleet good again
trying to
make plays for the team they're trying
to get into the paint they're right
there
van fleet with another three
shot by pooch rewarding the effort
lowry van fleet almost fired from deep
gets all the way to the basket lays it
in and a foul on the magic
but here's what i was talking about the
danger of closing out on
van fleet rebounded by lowry long throw
ahead to baines
norman powell underneath whips it out to
van fleet for three
my goodness fred van fleet you got to be
kidding me
that's his 10th three and 11 attempts
tonight since toronto's biggest lead
it's a dangerous time in the game
for the magic those three pointers well
they can just blow it up and so quick
van fleet with daylight he got another
one
that's 11 for fred van fleet and 12
attempts
from beyond the arc not shooting it
poorly david almost 50
field goal 39 from behind the arc can't
stop this guy
he's got 44.
[Applause]
we've got to take care of the basketball
he almost pulled the trigger there now
he drives again and lays it in again
fred van fleet adds two more to the
tally couldn't be happier because you're
watching a guy that is pretty much
unstoppable i thought he might have
gotten fouled on that one david looked
like his left
shoulder right there boy came wide open
someone went to sleep lowry got the
assist
been a couple of 60 point games this
year now van fleet with 50.
anthony's pass is going to set vanfleet
up for two more
just didn't have that set in his hands
so he moved it very quickly
13-point game man flee
able to escape two defenders now has 54
points
a raptors franchise high i keep talking
about his defense and
to him and have a special night like
this look at the kyle looking for him he
gets another
there it is the raptor record fred van
vleet